a town had a population of 11,000 256 in
1995 by 2010 the population in that town
had increased by four thousand three
hundred and twelve estimate the town's
population in 2010 by first rounding
these two numbers to the nearest hundred
so we could figure out the exact
population just by adding these two but
they want us to round to the nearest
hundred first and get an estimate and
then add so it'll be an estimate of the
town's population so first we have this
eleven thousand two hundred and fifty
six that's how that's the population in
nineteen ninety five eleven thousand two
hundred and fifty six we need a round to
the nearest hundred so let's look at the
hundreds place here so this is either
gonna go down to two hundred or go up to
three hundred depending on what the next
place is or the next lowest place so we
go down to the tens place we see a five
five is five or greater so we want to
round this number up we are going to
round up so if we round up to the
nearest hundred you get eleven thousand
instead of having 256 we're rounding up
to three hundred three hundred is closer
to 256 then two hundred is that's why
we're rounding up to that that's why
it's to the nearest hundred now we added
four thousand three hundred and twelve
people so four thousand three hundred
and twelve now once again we look at the
hundreds place we go one spot below that
we the question we're trying to answer
do we go down to four thousand three
hundred or do we go up to four thousand
four hundred which one is closer well we
see we only have a one here one is
definitely less than five so we wanna
round we want to round down so three
hundred twelve is closer to three
hundred we round down to just a three
here and these get zeroed out so four
thousand and three hundred and now we're
ready to add our rounded numbers 0 plus
0 is 0 0 plus 0 is 0 3 plus 3 is 6 let's
put a comma here so it's easy to read
every third digit 1 plus 4 is 5 and then
1 plus we have nothing here so we just
bring down that 1 and we could have
written in addition there we're adding
those two numbers so our estimate of the
town's population in 2010 is 15,000